[Music]  like so many government initiatives a  legal structure that began with  apparently good intentions has wrought  unintended consequences that are unjust  not merely to certain disenfranchised  groups but even to the people that  intended to help the road to hell is  paved with good intentions the  statistical moral and legal arguments to  end affirmative action are overwhelming  but here's the simplest the Justice  Department is entrusted with the  responsibility to stop discrimination  and protect civil rights for everybody  perhaps finally it ought to be able to  do just that I'm Michael Knowles this is  the Michael Knowles show  [Music]  [Music]